welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dhonia in the game
in the youtubes the three muslims it is
our pleasure to welcome you back for you
episode two of in person studio podcast
alhamdulillah with uh brother angel over
here on my left and brother ramy on my
right invited for you guys bismillah
how's it going guys
alhamdulillah things are good
things you're real good alhamdulillah we
got a beautiful sign up man i'm still
very proud of all this
to everyone who helped out very
beautiful thing
so
we've been talking a lot about uh
marriage relationships and all that
stuff and it's very popular as you
mentioned one of the most
viewed things when it comes to channels
especially muslim channels
uh found a lot and it's scarce nowadays
finding good marriages bro 60 divorce
rate uh
uh men being women and women being men i
don't just mean in terms of transgender
how dare you but men and women are equal
bro what are you saying
i mean equal in the sight of allah
but they're not exactly the same
and uh these you know differences matter
they need to be accounted for but before
we get to that
we we need to talk about you know how
you know what marriage is how do you get
married in the first place this kind of
climate
um
man honestly there are some crazy people
out there but honestly there are some
men some women that are crazy people out
there i tell the story a few times
i don't want to keep talking about the
sister but
this is just what comes to mind when i
talk about marriage bro
somebody who at one point wanted to
marry me
has flip-flopped back and forth about me
as a person on my tic toc so many times
first they like really liked me and my
tick tock and stuff and then the whole
thing like mahdi and all that happened
and
i made one like
a bit i guess ill-minded video
bro she was making dua against me in my
comments and all this crazy stuff and oh
[ __ ] then after that when it was done
she came back like nothing happened
there are some crazy people out there
yeah man after she was like oh i'm
always the first in your life and i'm
like
how dare you listen get the hell out of
here forget this men and women bs but
what you were saying about the whole
mahdi situation it reminded me of this
story i don't know if i should say it on
the podcast but i'll say just just it
was a learning curve for me too but
subhanallah there was there was a woman
sister who dm me
and said that you know i watched the
episode with you guys and mahdi and i
saw everything you guys had to say and
as a woman it really hurt my feelings
and it was taking a toll on my mental
health i was like so i don't love video
and then she was like yeah and uh it
pushed me so hard i wanted to take my
own life
and i was so new to
that i was in
and i'm sure all of us were at that time
that i genuinely didn't know if this was
something that i'll be held accountable
for is this something she's bluffing is
this something serious so i asked a lot
of misha i asked my sheikh and a couple
other chefs and they all told me the
same thing they said that these people
are always going to be here just looking
for attention looking for you know uh
any type of of input from you you know
any any any emotional response or
anything like that so best thing is
whatever they do they're gonna be held
accountable for you speak what you have
to speak because at the end of the day
you could say exactly what is in line
with huck and you will always have
people that will say something
so with that being said i learned my
lesson i still didn't reply to any of
those
comments or dm's but i spoke to uh one
of my
well beloved chefs i won't say the name
but he gave me the advice that i gave
you brothers that when it comes to the
social media and doing that or anything
like that
when you have a decent following just
stop reading comments
[Music]
now some people might say hey what about
the positive comments what about the
reinforcement what about the
the love
don't you want to read that
where are you guys with that
uh i don't honestly i don't it helps
it's nice i don't i don't need it i'd
rather and this is something especially
on tick-tock bro it's crazy man that's i
try and avoid comments as much as
possible because something i realize
with that same situation is the same
people that are praising you now will
absolutely hate you the next day
and you don't have to do anything absurd
you could just disagree with one small
thing an ichthy lafi issue a small thing
they will literally like hate you i'm
not even joking that term hate it's
strong but they will actually hate you
for it they will make sure you know in
the comments and the dm's and the
messages and all that subhanallah so i
stopped reading it all together i just
um i post it and i let it go i i mainly
look at the likes you know in the views
how many people saw it how many people
liked it and other than that i don't
really read comments so i just avoid it
all together
oh no what about you you've been in the
tubes longer than us
i mean it's the same thing though
and i had said the same thing to ramin
like when
when the whole
and the situation was going down and
romney was taking the heat big time oh
he was he was the one taking the e we
got him so like
having people make dua against him
that's that's tough she made dua against
me too that chick
yeah i remember that she literally said
i hope that you
uh never have kids and if you do i hope
that your wife you get a completely
miserable wife that's the exact woman
that you hate and i hope that your kids
grow up to hate you and not he's just
making so much dubs
and i was just like this is haram
haram what is she doing bro i had an
entire thread literally an entire thread
one person was like um uh i pray that
allah never gives you a wife or a
daughter and the literally just a bunch
of girls i mean i mean i mean a little
an entire thread
but that goes to showa and i remember i
told you i was like bro these people
they're not really with you yeah you
know like man bless them and like guide
them but
they ain't really with you bro and this
is something i learned being on youtube
for such a long time
that like yo one day
one day hey they're the best
they're like giving you the best
compliments like they're watching all
your stuff
and the next day they're over here like
throwing dirt on you so it's like
you you learn at some point to detach
from it yeah
because if not then you're gonna you're
gonna feel some type of way because it's
like you almost like getting attached to
what they're saying
yeah like if someone's giving you like
praise like
you start getting attached you're like
uh yeah like you know maybe maybe yeah
we are doing a good job maybe yeah he
goes to your head you know maybe yeah i
do have a nice voice maybe yeah like i
am helping out like
i am doing good here
but then they come at you and they're
like
say it all bro
then they come at you and then
they're pretty much
saying like are you a piece of
how dare you piece of trash
like you
i don't know man
it's
it's a human thing it's a natural thing
for us to feel some type of way about it
but it's like
again like
you have to make some kind of
discernment some kind of detachment from
it
yeah
looking back at the quran in cinema bro
i wanted to ask you a question that
the prophet saw and for all the lay men
and and were laymen too but the people
that don't know much about his life
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was he a man that got hate bro oh was he
a man that got opposition because people
might be like why are you guys talking
about hate why are you guys talking
about uh you know getting this these
comments and these these dms what does
it is does it even happen is it relevant
yeah i mean honestly i can firmly say if
you're not getting hated on you're doing
something wrong if people don't hate you
you're doing something wrong there's a
part of you that's trying to please
everyone and you're compromising the
message somehow because there's you know
damn well there are people out there
that completely hate islam so yeah but
let's not say if people like don't hate
you because if they only hate you
then you're probably doing something
wrong
there's a saying you know if i had six
people i'd rather three of them
extremely love me and three of them
extremely hate me but all six of them
know me 100
instead of all six of them kinda know me
kinda don't
once i'm passed you know they're not
gonna know much about me what i stood
for yeah i'm 100 percent now the prophet
alaihistan just go to go back to the
initial point
um a man hate is an understatement
attempts on his life complete boycott uh
and that causes uncle and his wife who
he loved very very much to die and with
his uncle that died
and uh
to his uncle that died when he died his
protection for the process on him died
with it right he died with him so he
lost his wife
uncle and protection and he had to go to
different tribes and seek protection and
so on and so forth so this was a man
solar system who was at one point so
loved by the community so respected he
was known as the trustworthy and the
honest and someone with the best
honestly amazing character people loved
him so much
and then as soon as he portrays this
message of islam and it causes people to
come and accept islam and worship god
alone and keep in mind all he was doing
especially in the beginning was
basically telling them worship allah
alone abandoned the idols
that's basically all he was saying
they didn't have it attempts on his life
hatred uh slander
everything man
everything and honestly what happened to
me i i don't even want to say that
sounds so cringy it happened to me i
didn't get i didn't die nothing happened
when you think of the prophet saws yeah
they saw something exactly like it was
so soft there was nothing like a few
people behaving oh okay i'm gonna cry
about it okay i'll move on shall
everyone moves on the process
man he had to put ali in his bed
because there were people coming to kill
him in the sleep while he fled to
another city
so i mean the comments that happened
they got to it is what it is and and it
really shows you that in the modern
world the words they use were misogynist
homophobe
bigot all these terms that they use
world they they're really powerless at
the end of the day in the eyes of allah
yeah because at the end of the day are
you speaking truth or are you speaking
falsehood are you working for allah for
the devil and i think that's all that
matters bro it doesn't matter what the
people say yeah 100 100.
i mean people try and put you in a box
all the time i think you guys notice
that as well you know the whole oh
you're homophobic you're misogynist
you're a blah blah blah blah extremist
extremist is the big one bro barbaric
yeah even bro my my fiance called an
extremist by his sister because she was
trying to say this is what hijab is
we're not an extremist but she's like
you know oh i see you follow the extreme
viewer there's something something like
that you mentioned use that wording it's
like
yeah you're gonna try and put me in a
box just to dismiss what i'm saying
that's what they do when they call you
homophobia is because they don't want to
actually address what you've said
and i think honestly i see that when i
when i see these tactics i basically
feel like i've won you know what i mean
like you know i don't want to use this
kind of example but you know when you're
trying to get someone mad and they get
mad at you like you feel like you won
don't do that right
this is haram
but
when you know when you see these tactics
come up and the guy in the video we
reacted to remember the the documentary
was a woman it's like matt walsh you
probably at that point you think
probably thinking i won he's done bro
that's it
yeah
um
it reminds me when matt walsh was
talking to that college professor and he
was like i don't like that you're
probing i don't like the word truth
unlike the terminology you're using how
about we talk about what we're talking
about at hand and forget all these extra
things that you guys are throwing away
you get me
i feel like we've been all over the damn
place but it's okay
because at the end of the day that's
what conversations are like
i do want to eventually bring it back to
marriage we started off with that but
this is just how conversation let's go
yeah bro stop stop being weird about it
brother no no i got it
i do feel like just i was saying like
i'm i've literally had to like take a
step back and like really just
like wait where are we right now what
are we talking let us know in the
comments guys if you want genuine
unscripted conversations like this one
or if you prefer the more
focused and and
not scripted but ones that stick to one
point i personally like this yeah it's
more fun it's more engaging less heavy
on the soul i do think we're going a
little hard with the sound bites though
for sure let's let's take a step back
then oh no what are you doing bro it's a
art it's all right
so you gotta just
lessons more listen bro with great power
comes great responsibility
i don't have a sound body for that so
yeah i'm all upstairs no no you're
saying we're too trigger-happy yeah
right now yes
i'm fighting the urge to press it
how dare you
that's the last one but uh yeah let's
let's let's bring back to the wrong
relationships thing why are we talking
about
why are we talking about hatred why are
we talking about getting hate and how
does this link to haram relationships
well it's very simple the thing is
we need to understand what is good hate
and what is bad hate what is good
criticism and what is bad criticism
there's been too many of us that are
getting roped into haram relationships
which is a very slippery slope and they
don't want to listen to anyone's nasiha
people come to them and they're like hey
bro
you know and i understand you know you
you're convinced you're going to marry
her you know or someone comes to a
sister and say yeah i understand he says
he's going to marry you you know but
right now you guys still haven't you
know gotten gotten married he's on the
cat you know
is that really hate no but they take it
as hate you know that's different than
the the type of hate we were talking
about which is genuinely just people
that wake up and they choose violence
you know we're talking about the people
that come at you with proper nursing
here the way brother and i talked about
the last episode with the other right
but
it's it's such a slippery slope bro
subhanallah and i see people so you know
so many people around me
they they they think they're not in a
haram relationship but i would
definitely consider that a harambe
relationship i don't know if you know
what i mean yeah i just have a question
though like
it's not always
picturesque it's not always like picture
perfect you know what i'm saying
like it's not like oh i found the hijabi
let me talk to her dad right away
you know like that's not how it is
and that's why i feel like a lot of um
a lot of brothers kind of get this
mixed up and and i'm not even saying
like they're doing it badly but they're
trying to find they're trying to follow
the sunnah right it's just how we should
be doing it like as a as a man you
should you know when you meet a girl
like her
you got to make it proper you you talk
to the wali and then you do everything
supervised and all this but like let's
be honest
there's a lot of brothers out here who
are
doing it slightly different
and i mean i'm not here to say oh this
this is permissible i'm not one to even
be able to say that
but there are some brothers that have
done this some brothers and sisters
and
[Music]
allah has been barakah in their
relationship so
the question is like
what is what is truly truly proper in
this day and age
i think that those that understand
and are on deen and they understand that
being in a haram relationship is haram
being with the non-muharram woman
no nikah
no intentions of getting married
i think that's a that's a dangerous
place to be bro yeah what can you define
being with what do you mean when you say
dating zina
but if if someone let's see
and i'm gonna what i'm gonna say is
technically i'm not gonna give like a
fifth answer on this but let's say you
have a muslim guy and a muslim girl you
know they're both born into islam
whether they've been taught the deen
properly or not that's not on me
but let's say they're dating
you know
they're not practicing they're probably
not praying
and let's say then they start praying
and practicing
you know and they repent they ask for
forgiveness
and they truly fix their ways and shall
allah the most merciful let's assume
allah forgives them
you know if you know
if that's the scenario
then are we really to judge
i mean it's one of the things you have
to leave to allah at the end of the day
you know because us us as humans we see
something wrong we speak against it we
advise we move on you know we
it's not our job even to really
make any judgment or any final say we
just you know samia and our author now
we hear we right so we see something
wrong correct
move on in life
yeah all day yeah the people watching
this most of the people watching it or
maybe even some i don't think there's
those people bro these are the people
telling us yo don't type this don't type
that don't do this don't do that
so i'm pretty sure
just uh what what is it um
just just some advice
you know and they mean well inshallah
but a lot of the times people like
context and and and
understanding the full perspective bro
yeah that's why i'm here i'm trying to
raise these
questions of i'm getting more
comfortable here
it's so weird by just having this thing
like in my face it just violates me bro
i was gonna press something bro so hard
but i didn't hold up
prom
what oh it's because the army paused
halfway but we got to let them play
through all the way
um
sorry bro what's in your face and it
makes you feel uncomfortable
no no i forget that i'm okay i'm saying
though like
in these situations man like let's say
you have let's see you have a practicing
brother
and you're a practicing sister right and
they're doing their thing that god
fearing
let's say they meet
they're online because bro we live we
live in the day and age world
come on now come on now
let's see let's be honest all right so
they meet online
and um it's very like
it's nothing crazy it's it's not like
what
the like kuffar would do or like someone
who's really trying to commit sin i hate
that we talk
one of the most common words i hear on
jose today is cafe
is another word
yes i just like how it rolls off the it
does
very
easy on the tongue but um
yeah so they meet you know they're
talking and for the most part it's like
it's
it's innocent you know it's platonic but
then you know like they both have the
intention of like getting to know each
other
for marriage
and um from there you know they start
talking a little bit more they start
getting to know each other then
the brother is like okay i want to talk
to you ali now you look at this
situation here
and it's it's not by any means like
proper
because like the the brother didn't go
to the wali first
i like he started talking to the sister
getting to know her sister and all this
stuff so i was like bro i'm just
genuinely curious man because like we
live in a day and age when like this
this happens bro and like
we could say like oh bro we're like
happy people this is not right this is
not how it should be but like then again
a lot of wills a lot wills
and you have a lot of barakah in these
situations
see this reminds me of one of the first
things that i noticed about gibril you
know
it was very old bro it was about a year
ago when we started the podcast and
brother gabriel was saying you know his
whole motto with his channel is real
problems real solutions he said exactly
what ana was saying that there's the
problems that people think we have and
then there's what's actually going down
behind closed doors you know there's
this whole false
that oh no one's here you know touching
themselves let's see no one's here
committing zinna
it's not actually happening brother
why are you talking about these things
bro wallahi these things are so common
and a man and a woman are not together
except that shaytan is the third person
in the room so what you're saying is a
very slippery slope and easy to fall
into
you know it might start very innocently
oh i'm for sure gonna marry them you
know so it doesn't matter if i do it now
or do it after marriage i'm gonna marry
them for sure what's the difference why
wait
you know she wants it i wanted to
but wallahi there's there's wisdom and
following the rules and barriers that
allah has put
you know yeah yeah bro there's been so
many stories that people have said that
and it just does not work out
and then after that like you know i
wasted all this time this money this
effort i lost my virginity to this
person and now i feel connected with
them and it didn't work out because my
dad decided one day he's not good enough
and you know you know yeah it's crazy
man but i'm not referring to like the
zinna
component of it i'm referring to like
they're talking
um you know they really like each other
they want to get to know each other for
you know the intention of marriage
and
the brother he then says to the sister
let me speak to you wally you know i
would like to make this official i would
like to get the ball rolling here
and in that case like
they're not
engaging in intimacy beforehand they're
not doing any
zinna they're not um
talking to each other
um flirting or talking about things
which
they shouldn't it's not halal it's not
permissible at that time being right
like
you know
the good stuff
but
this is haram
haram this is that's what i'm saying
we're not talking about that that's you
don't speak about that
so
in this case
right they're doing everything as halal
as
they possibly can at this point
and um they refrain from like
overstepping the boundaries
transgressing you know i'm saying they
they're keeping that that taqwa few of
them which which boundaries though the
boundaries that they set for themselves
are the ones by allah the ones by the
law it's just at
in that situation the way that it got to
that point it's like okay they didn't
start proper proper
but they are proper now um you see what
i'm saying that's what i'm like trying
to figure out here like what about those
situations yeah i mean i have heard
sheil say that you know if
because in this in this time
unfortunately it's hard to even find a
woman that will let you go to her father
um before even speaking to you once you
know what i mean it's a
it's understandable and a lot of the
time it's because the father right if a
father is open to it like i don't care
if you bring me you know 10 guys and
then i disapprove of all of them and
then the 11th i'm cool with i don't care
if you go to this talking stage you know
10 11 times that's how it works
um then maybe his daughter won't be as
closed off to it right but you have a
lot of fathers though that are like well
you already brought them to me like you
i already told you know half the family
about it it has to go through you can't
stop this you can't kiss it so it's a
big issue so some i've heard
that if you're gonna have one or two
conversations three conversations just
to know them to see if they're just at
least the bare minimum if that's there
and you are interested to you know
getting to know them for marriage after
you get to a point where you've talked
enough and you both are fairly confident
then you can go to diwali and make it
official and so on and so forth
so that's fine
i'm not saying i can't say it's fine
but there's levels to what you could do
bro a man came to the prophet saw and
and you know was talking about this
woman and the prophet saw was saying
okay okay i understand this but did you
see her
yeah and he said no
and then he said sallallahu salaam go
see her
this doesn't mean go see her wear
something provocative
this doesn't mean go go in with my
intent
but
looks are important in a marriage
and of course we're not
we're not here acting fake pious
no dirt to the christians though you
know may allah guide you all
but we're not here saying stuff like we
stay celibate and stuff like that you
know we're we're dealing with reality
here so so we understand that men have
needs and women have needs
and looks are extremely important for
both sexes so the prophet sallam
with all of his amazing um
wisdom and and insightfulness
salah
he said did you see her he asked did you
see her
you know so can you see any woman
without the intention of marriage no i
don't think so bro but can you see a
woman that you're serious about and you
want to propose to of course
you know
yeah i just think
there's a disconnect
with the
[Music]
shakes
you know
i'm not not questioning their knowledge
or
authority on certain points but i'm just
i feel like there's a disconnect
in terms like what brother gabriel said
like in terms of
what we think
is happening and what's really happening
you know and like
with this disconnect
um
there's not a lot of understanding for
certain situations
that are going down
do you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
100
this unfortunately a lot of a lot of
shaykh are out of touch with the
problems that you know kids face
nowadays
and uh maybe kids the wrong term to use
even young adults that they face
nowadays um and not just to share with
the parents as well bro like a parent
will be so happy sending their daughter
or their son to university with a lot of
you know 21 18 to 20
honestly as old as they might be people
in the peak yeah at their peak of their
sexual drive and like one of the hottest
sexual climates there could be
um you know in this high stress area as
well where people are really really
trying to um you know press some
people's buttons and stuff
that's it bro that's literally what it
is um and uh they're completely fine and
sending the child there right but but
you know oh you're only you're only 18
you're only 20 how could you get married
you did a study yeah
he can say that the father can say that
without due respect but he can go go
home go to his wife yeah who's warm and
ready masha allah yeah and he won't have
to think about that yeah yeah and this
is where i feel like
there needs to be more light shed
you know like
in real life scenarios like this because
it's like man like
you got this kid
on this brother right he's going to
college
a lot of bad things out there man a lot
of bad teams walking around out there
and you know you know damn while they're
walking out there with nothing on almost
yeah
and like yeah he can
he could try to lower his gaze but how
was that gonna work
yeah how was he gonna lower his gaze and
then
this is what i'm saying i'm not i'm not
against it i'm not against like the
traditional aspect i love the
traditional aspect but i just feel like
there is context and with that context
it needs to be addressed so that those
who are going through these real life
situations can actually maneuver through
them appropriately bro the modern day
practicalities right now are completely
lacked by the average khutbah that i go
to
oh yeah of course they're talking about
you know in the times of the prophet
saws this was happening and why are we
talking about these stories we have to
because these stories are are either
from the quran or from the seed of the
prophet salaam and all these authentic
narrations masha allah and there's
immense wisdom in it and it's sufficient
islam is a complete thing we don't need
anything else
but
no one's talking about what's happening
today no one's talking about when you go
on snapchat bro you can't even see
someone's story without seeing all this
fitna you can't even search someone's
name on instagram without seeing the
explore page and seeing all this garbage
yeah you can't even go on youtube
without these stupid ads bro no one's
talking about this yeah that's true but
they're talking about you know bro lower
your gaze allah is always watching
understand that but when you talk in
that way if a brother is struggling with
let's say
touching himself and he's addicted to
that and watching haram how is he going
to feel comfortable coming to you after
the khutba and and getting someone to
see even bro he's completely going to be
shut off from that yeah 100 were these
topics taboo bro from the prophet saws
no no no not at all
he would talk about i mean yes he would
use very kind and sensitive language but
he'll talk about it very clear even
allah
or basically he says you know your women
are like your your land that you till
you can approach or enter it from any
direction
so what's your course
and he talked with the shabbat
and prophet saw some talk to the youth
where is this false piety coming from
then
i don't know but all i know is that go
and bro go to masajid or go to one of
the masajid right go to masjid give one
khutbah and say the most real stuff you
could think of they will never let you
back in that measure you
how dare you
so delayed
no no they will not speak you're gonna
be cancelled yeah it's honestly it's
because a lot of these these massages
they honestly they kind of have to be
careful because
you know if someone says the wrong thing
and you know
the government or whatever the people
don't like it it's going to be bad for
them see but this is where the problem
is man like
this
i feel like that's not real islam that's
that's like filtered look to this line
it is it's watered down you know like we
need that real stuff and again like the
traditional like there's nothing wrong
with the traditional i love the
traditional yeah this is what islam is
is the traditional but at the end of the
day
in this day that we live in
yeah things are different yeah and it
needs to be addressed
and we need to know exactly how we can
maneuver these things how can a brother
who's in college really lower his gaze
how can he really best do these things
and then it brought him
it it makes me a little heated
like when my channel where i talk about
semen retention
and i have actual you got
i actually have some brothers
who try to tell me like oh brother this
is
this is kufr
this is not of the of islam this is like
this is nowhere in islam you should
never be doing this like i i encourage
you to go to the quran listen okay i get
it quran sunnah perfect
but you know what if you remove the
label
the practice in and of itself
you're refraining and if you if you're
not married if you're a brother in
college and you have all these women
around you they're pretty much half
naked or almost completely naked
actually let's be honest yeah
bro seeming retention is like the best
thing that you could do at that point
yeah
oh but you know what
this
this is person here that said it's not
part of islam so i shouldn't even
practice this so then what should i do
i mean you know yeah if you look at what
the prophet saw said he said you know
get married if you can't then fast
because fasting kills sexual drive so
even the process them is trying to say
like you should lower your sexual drive
and obviously so you can avoid it right
so you don't you know you know the the
fastest time he didn't say you know
masturbate or anything like that if you
can't get married or you know you know
in some scholars they say if you feel
like you're going to fall into the zen
it's halal for you so on and so forth
but only if it's really extreme so don't
take it out of context yeah but you know
subhanallah even the process was saying
you know fast so it can lower the sexual
drive
but what i'm trying to get at is that
there's
context
right if you understand the context
you understand how to go about the
situation how to maneuver how to really
give someone nasiha advice yeah in that
particular situation yeah you know like
i've been in that situation where i
didn't have
i didn't have a wife i didn't have a
girlfriend and all i had was all these
girls around me who were basically
pretty much naked
and like at that point like i knew okay
i'm trying to
practice this whole nofap this whole
human intention thing
and therefore this is what i have to do
i have to stay more busy
i have to focus more on myself my
hobbies and growing as an individual
right and it's like
okay maybe you see my attention isn't in
islam right
but look at what i just said
like growing as an individual
focusing on yourself building this stuff
like wouldn't that be proper nasiha to
give to a brother who's in college who's
around all these not sisters but who's
around all these women
he's around another fitnah but you tell
him look
right now
fast
fast as much as you can yeah and make
sure you just focus as much of your
energy as possible
not only into your school but also to
yourself improve be the best man best
the best muslim that you can be
and get right with allah yeah and allah
will open the doors for you
and then when you get married
it's different then we'll address it
then but let's take care of this here
you know like that's proper nasi yeah
that's proper context of understanding
and that's actually applying the
traditional aspect actual islam bro how
powerful is that bro to be honest
because you're applying islam with
proper context you're not taking things
out of context you're not taking things
and misquoting it from the quran from
the hadith yeah because what's the
alternative you tell you tell a brother
listen
lower your gaze you shouldn't be you
know worried about it just focus on
school you're there to study
but school is going to tell you to pass
this one class you need to get into this
group assignment and this project you
need to do this presentation with you
know and the random assignment so they
put you in a group of four girls
women outweigh men in post-secondary
education
many fold let's just say that
most of the classes i took in in
pre-med and undergrad
i was either the only guy in a class of
30 to 60 maybe even 90. if not one of
two to three guys
everyone else is a woman
look at the ratio bro
that's great you're telling me oh just
just focus on school bro of course i'm
there for school i'm not gonna deny it
but why can we not talk about these
things bro why can't we not give sincere
nasia and and why is there always haram
police after us trying to say you know
like you're doing too much bro you're
speaking too much if you say this it's
gonna open them up to this bro what do
you mean it's gonna we're not even
talking about that though yeah
why are you thinking about that huh
you know
yeah yes i mean even when i like when it
comes to in general rulings like
everything is halal or proven haram
right it's not it's not the opposite way
around where everything's haram until
you find a hadith that allows it right
it's not it's like that with al-qaeda
it's not like that with
so if you were to give someone the
advice that you gave them no one can
come to you and say oh the prophet
didn't say to do that you know it's like
okay
so
does the prophet need to tell me you use
my phone don't use my phone he didn't
have a phone back then that's why they
have chaos you know like also
is very very very
very in-depth masha'allah and i barely
understand it right to be completely
fair but um the tools that they use
right the general um
um
the general rulings and using chaos and
all these things
bro it's
it's mind-numbing for me to even think
about right but it's so in-depth for
anyone come to come and say oh it's not
from the sun or something it's like bro
do you even understand to begin with to
say it's not from the sunnah because not
everything you are allowed to do needs
to be specifically from the son of the
pro
is it is it permissible if it's
permissible why are you uh hating on me
for it
so what do we what do we do with these
people because there's two there's two
schools of thought right now one is
the problem are the individuals
the people that are here making duck
fear on anything that walks by in front
of them and just always having an issue
with everything taking things out of
context always judging
you know
and there's also people thinking okay no
the problem is actually not them because
they're always going to be there the
problem is the people you know the
people out here too sensitive and too
soft and they just always listen to
these people if someone says yo bro why
do you have you know this behind you on
your shelf that's haram bro take it down
and you just take it down and you just
always you know play by these games
so like who's to blame bro
whoever doesn't have the correct
understanding of this number and if it's
both of them it's both of them right um
i think uh a problem can have many roots
right multiple roots and um i think
there's a little bit of blame in in
every party to be honest um
if you have people
that are so superficial in their
understanding of islam that they're
going to come and be like
you know oh the prophet at least also
didn't have shelves you know it's like
honestly you need sometimes you need to
give them a lesson you need to teach
them that in everything is halal into a
proven haram if you say that i'm not
allowed to have a shelf behind me you
need to provide evidence for it that's
that's a bada bro that's an innovation
they didn't use shelves back then
there's gonna be people like that though
it just makes me like
again just
it really makes me question things
because it's like
someone could say oh that's that's not
islamic
what other things that we do in our
lives that aren't islamic but i mean
it's not haram what does that even mean
islamic that's that's the thing because
if you look islam encompasses everything
right and and it would be wrong to say
that there's things that islam does
encompass for anything you can find in
life islam will have some kind of ruling
on it most of the i don't say most of
the time a lot of the time you'll find
the ruling is halal the ruling is that
it's okay or worst case scenario it's
it's it's uh dislikes
right and say worst case scenario
omitting sinful obviously worst case
scenario it's not a sin it would just be
mukur right and i'm not saying that like
it was just but you wouldn't be sinful
if you did whatever it is right
95 percent of
95 of of rulings
are
there's a difference of opinion you'll
go to two three four different
one will say it's it's permissible one
will say it's uh disliked the other one
will say it's uh it's sinful
and uh fourth one i know whatever and he
makes some analogy allah adam right
whatever uh you'll find different
rulings because
he says in the quran two verses i want
to give one
uh chapter i think chapter three surah
al-imran verse 7
he says that this is the book that we
have revealed in it are verses that are
they're clear cut
right meaning that there's only one
meaning it's very clear-cut like
it's very clear you can't understand
that in any other way then say he is
allah the one and only easy
then he says
and others other verses are ambiguous
muta be had you could they could be
understood different ways right and
there are ayats like that like um
where allah talks about the uh
weight three uh periods basically is it
for the woman after a divorce is it
three months
is it three menstrual cycles and there's
many examples of this but if you look at
you know other places in the quran allah
he says
if you don't know ask those who know
right if you don't know what to do
because you're struggling because you're
suffering university there's girls all
around you flaunting yourself at you
and you go to shaykh
actually might not know what you should
he might know the ruling
you know it's haram for you to look
lower your gaze and i'm not trying to
disrespect you they're amazing allah
reward them and bless i'm not saying
they're not trying to act like they're
these old out of touch idiots no
may allah reward them and bless them
all i'm saying is that they might not be
as aware as someone like you you know
someone comes to you and they say on
hell bro you know i love your channel
insha'allah keep up the good work uh i
have this trouble you know i have this
struggle my parents want me to go uni i
want to make them happy i want my
education there are girls everywhere bro
i went to my sheikh he said lower your
gaze it's not enough for me what should
i do you know i don't know you know let
me know in sha allah you give him the
advice boom can anyone come and say oh
no that's harambro the process he said
in the hadith
if you can't get married fast why are
you telling this guy to work out in the
gym
it's like yani okay you can relay the
hadith process and fast it was also only
the first two days of the week you have
you have you know
more days inshallah just to work out and
stuff
what's wrong with it so i think that
would be my overall arching answer islam
covers everything
but you have to be on you have to
understand islam from the first place to
even talk about the rulings um
that makes sense for them
because it is it's giving credit where
credit is due
to the actual you know the shake yeah
but it's also saying like look
uh if y'all ever heard that same way
it's like if you if you're trying to do
something
then look for someone who's already done
it yeah
so you can get the best
advice the best guidance in that in that
path that you're going on right and
that's what you just mentioned right
there you just clearly said it where
it's like okay
um my shaykh said this
not enough for me but look i see you
you've done this you've been through
this
tell me tell me what you did and maybe
you know maybe it might help me right
yeah and like i'm really thinking about
this man because i think this is um i
think this is a breakthrough
because many brothers and many sisters
need to hear this bro yeah well
and it's reminding me of um
this thing as well
where in i made the video about
the whole human intention i also made
we're gonna get into this because like
we gotta get deep into the uh intimacy
stuff here but i had spoken about
this thing that you do
during intimacy which allows the man to
uh
control himself right and without
getting too much details you don't get
too much it allows a man to control
himself to where he can decide if he
wants to release or not release
meaning that
it's it's not just going to last a few
minutes
it could last however long as he or she
or both of them wanted to less now i
actually got a lot of heat for this
a lot of brothers were saying how dare
you
oh bro i'm saying i got a lot of heat
for this because people were saying like
oh this is this is not a part of islam
like oh like it should be it's fine to
release look i'm not saying it's not
like you shouldn't no one's giving a
shout-out you ruling yeah i'm not even
giving a ruling bro we're saying how to
enhance your intimacy yeah and isn't it
you just said okay everything is
halal on this
and in intimacy yeah
i think the only thing that's haram is
three things the three things rule of
threes so nothing in the booty hole
nothing from the back end yeah nothing
from the back
no uh
no busting in the mouth
you can bust okay stuck from my brother
you could finish you can release
during oral if you were a man
receiving oral however majority of
scholars uh unanimously agree that since
you are releasing nudges
nadja said it's impure she cannot
swallow
and lastly
come on bro you want to help him out
with the save
specific time of the month
uh during the the menzies yeah and allah
knows best these are the three main
things we should stay away from because
they're unanimously majority scholarly
opinion or in the quran
impermissible
but everything else goes if we're
thinking about this now you can engage
in intimacy
and
for the most part the other things are
hella they're permissible right so then
this also means that the method
of being able to withhold and not
release
is also permissible for the most part
because it's not it's not doing anything
it's not going against
like it's not going against any rulings
so then when someone's trying to write
it off because they don't understand it
it's kind of like what that thing that
you were saying where like
um when someone tries to say they try to
put you in this box
just so they can discredit what you're
saying yeah
you hear what i'm saying so it's like i
don't know i'm just i'm making a lot of
connections here yeah yeah yeah yeah 100
bro 100
um and subhanallah i think it always
boils down to people's ignorance on it
um
i don't want to repeat myself but i do
kind of want to
break down something you mentioned
before
if and this is the actual concept this
is actually necessary i would say it's
necessary for doing it she had if any
scholar
and i say scholar because there are a
lot of people who are non-scholars to
try and give fataway and stuff that
they're making up allah you know forgive
us and guide us but the ones who are
supposed to so for a shaykh to do it
which means linguistically basically
exhausting all effort to try and find a
ruling
if it has to do with something specific
like let's say financials right maybe
banking maybe cryptocurrency let's use
that example it's big now cryptocurrency
even for the chef to even really make a
ruling on it he needs to understand what
the it's called um
i forget what it's called but the
reality
right the reality of the situation and
for him to know what the reality of
cryptocurrency is
uh he'd be allowed to make a ruling so
if let's say the cryptocurrency um uses
interest reba and it's very heavy and
it's a specific contract with the person
who's buying and selling the crypto
that would make it haram because it's it
involves rubber right
if he didn't know that and he's like oh
it's just trading like the stock market
as long as the cryptocurrency company
isn't doing anything haram you're good
to buy well
he would have made a mistake in that
case because he just doesn't know the
reality of the situation and that ties
in a lot to what we're talking about
because and a lot of people don't know
it's unfortunately
for every ruling you have
it's actually it's very
hard very rare to find a ruling in stem
that is consistent in every single
situation
you know you shouldn't lie well if your
life's at stake then you can lie you can
do take if someone's like putting a gun
to your head if you can't eat pork it's
haram you know there are guys out here
that they'll do anything except eat pork
because it's harassing may allah protect
us
but if you're dying in the middle of the
desert or somewhere in the wilderness
and pork is the only thing there to eat
you're actually
it's actually ford it's obligatory if
you eat that pork now so you can survive
because in different situations
it will take on a different ruling hold
up that lying thing i thought that was
only for like the shias
a lot so i mean the shay as the way
people talk about shares using takea is
like the lie in any situation like let's
say i have a weird belief uh i don't
want to use the shias because i don't
want to you know say anything out of
pocket but let's say let me use ahmadis
right let's say
how dare
um
if i didn't want you to know that
takiyah in this case would be like no no
no i don't believe that we don't even
believe that come follow my sect but we
don't believe that don't worry that's
okay straight up that's not even okay
that's straight up lying that's how some
shares practice it
in sunny islam the way it's actually
allowed is if someone comes to you right
and they put a gun to your head and
they're like you need to tell me you
know let's say they want to harm your
family you need to tell me where your
family is right now
you can say okay they're they're east
they drove 20 miles east and they're
actually 30 miles west right or north
northwest or whatever that's allowed
that's takiyah allah makes it
permissible in cases like that but the
point is that if you had someone who
doesn't understand islam they're going
to sit there like
my family's there do what you got to do
i can't lie
you know
you take things out of context in that
case yeah 100 you generalize and
extrapolate based on your own limited
human finite understanding of the
rulings of allah which are so vast and
they're so nuanced and it's not black
and white bro yeah but it's so easy to
just look at someone and say yo you're
wearing tattoos bro therefore you're a
kafir first of all what how do you wear
tattoos that's i don't understand this
you got tattoos you don't know if he's a
reaver you don't know if allah has
forgiven them and maybe outwardly you
might think they have a lot of sins but
inwardly they're pure and maybe inwardly
you know you're completely destroyed
and you have all these sins that no one
can see and outwardly you're putting on
this nice facade that you're perfect and
that you're sinless
no one no one no one there dares to like
look deeper than what meets the eye
today bro
it's like that one picture
that shows um
the iceberg yeah yeah it's a
editor bro if you could put this picture
on it's the picture of the iceberg with
uh you know the top and what you don't
see it's like a deeper iceberg under the
water and no one sees it they just see
the tip of the iceberg and then there's
another iceberg it's mainly above the
water and there's barely anything under
it bro yeah yeah and then the one was
like barely anything under it's like
basically showing
like uh
i guess
the things that these people are doing
that's
um the good stuff the internal stuff the
real stuff maybe there's nothing it's
all outward exactly and that's not going
to care bro allah is not going to reward
good action without good intention or
good intention without good action yes
100
very beautifully said uh we have a few
minutes left so we have to wrap up and i
think we should inshallah circle back to
the initial question that was asked
which does in a way tie into a few
different things of course you don't it
was so long ago
how does a muslim get married in this
day and age
okay so
um again i believe we made this
breakthrough so number one
this is in my opinion my humble opinion
y'all please jump in
add on to it or dissect it however you
want but i believe that first um you
have to have the the proper nia
proper intention go on to that bro you
gotta have the proper nia
um
just think about it like okay your
intention is to get married yeah if your
intention is to get married then you
should be getting all your things right
with allah
if this is not right with allah like i'm
sorry but where you at what do you what
is your intention then like what are you
trying to get married for because like
listen i can speak for myself
when i didn't have everything like
proper proper
i can't say i'm like perfect or anything
but when i have anything like proper
my neo was definitely like oops yeah
it was my nuts like i was just trying to
fulfill the nufs like
guys it's like you you guys know me too
damn well so
that's what it is man so first
yeah have the intention
um and
second is obviously the action yeah you
know properly
be going about doing these things to get
closer to allah to learn more about
islam and all this stuff and um number
three
is consult consult
right shake get proper opinions
from people who actually know more than
you
and then after this
look for people who've already done it
you know maybe look for other brothers
and sisters who've
maybe been in your situation so that you
can get
um
[Music]
i guess proper context proper feedback
proper experience proper stories or
whatever they're willing to say
because that can give you the insight
that you require
in order to
you know make something happen
and then like lastly lastly lastly
is um
yeah praise the heart
hmm
praise the lord because like
it was until
actually i came to speak for myself and
i don't want to speak for myself but for
many brothers and sisters it's not until
they praise tahara that they see the
things really begin to happen granted
they're taking care of everything else
to touch into number four bro out of
your five points masha'allah tabata
there's a lot of sites we won't mention
them right
islamic websites where you get fatawa
and i generally believe they're doing
more good than
harm
so i won't mention them
and a lot of today on youtube
they're doing more good than harm in my
opinion therefore we won't mention them
right
and we're cognizant of the shortcomings
and faults that we have internally so
we might be beneath them who knows of
course
but
i stopped you know reading a lot of
these
websites and listening to a lot of these
chefs we were talking about it this week
because the way they approach
fatawa or rulings and jurisprudence in
islam which is such a nuanced topic
subhanallah is in a very black or white
scenario yeah
it's always haram
this is always haram
cryptocurrency is undoubtedly haram
xyz is
and if you do this you're subbing into
kufur
same with these websites you know
there's nothing wrong with giving fatal
that are actually based
you get me but there's so many that are
just pulling things out of thin air and
making the life of a men today in the
modern day society much more difficult
than has to be yeah and now i'm not here
being an enabler to anyone that wants to
go smoke weed saying oh it doesn't say
weed in the quran therefore i can smoke
weed
listen
what did rami say to that brother that
said uh there's receptors in the brain
for weed
i don't know say it as it is bro
i mean you also have a g-spot in your
bum right
yeah for men so that doesn't mean you
should you know be
stimulating it this is haram
haram that's what it is so it yes we use
harsh examples sometimes to make these
analogies but
it's the same paradigm bro they're
analogous so at the end of the day what
i'm trying to say is as men and women
today that are trying to be good muslims
and good muslims
learn your religion understand your
religion understand your context right
but know who to take advice from and who
to not take advice from and this doesn't
mean now you only go to the sheikh that
affirms your beliefs and you stay away
from the sheikhs that are going against
your beliefs this is not what we're
saying either now you guys are are
taking words out of our mouth
because oftentimes it's the hard advice
that you need to follow and the easy
advice that you need to forgo but what
we're saying is understand the context
and the nuances and most of the time you
already know intuitively with your fitra
which one's the right answer which one's
the wrong answer and have the
testicular fortitude if you're a man to
follow that
and uh
i guess piety as a woman to follow that
simple
and before before you go bro um i think
this is very very
important
because
dude like you got to play this side
for everything
you got to play this out to even like
where you're going to be getting your
information from like which scholar
you're going to be getting information
from i bro i saw this thing where it's
like you know what it should be to the
point where you're literally asking a
lot for guidance for a broken slipper
like allah what should i do my slipper
broke it's like really it's not that big
of a dude but no no bro but like when
you are going through a lot even for the
smallest things
bro yeah yeah that shows like how much
you trust salaam allah loves this right
so you should definitely be praying this
sahara for this
but
it's so important that you're not
getting the information
from a source that's just not
for you it doesn't necessarily see
princess's hair just floating everywhere
it's not to say that like this
this person of knowledge they're saying
something wrong is to say that you know
what
and maybe their message is just not
meant for you um right
and and i'll give you a perfect example
when i was in thailand there's his
brother that i met
and every time we go to the masjid
he
wouldn't pray
in the congregation
he would actually be outside of the
masjid and he would pray by himself
and i was like bro like why are you
knowing that there's more buttercup
praying together yeah like
there's way more barakah right and then
i asked him and he's like oh
um the shade that i follow they say that
um
there should not be space
between the the brothers
in the congregation that's
understandable but like we're in a
different country
this they're just
doing what they have to do from
government regulation and stuff like i
get it would be best for us to be like
shoulder to shoulder ankle to ankle but
you know like the fact is we're still
here we're still in the the masjid we're
still praying and like even though
there's this this is going on like we're
still here we're still praying so why
not receive that barakah and then he's
like no no brother like you don't
understand there is no barakah like the
prayer is invalid i'm like really he's
gay look this shaker saying bro when he
was showing me what these shakes were
saying
this was some
extreme stuff this was some extreme
stuff and like
i had a another brother that i was
staying with out there and he was like
bro like why are you making it so hard
for yourself like
you you aren't even like going further
to seek even more knowledge over what
you're doing and then i asked i asked
him i really asked him i was like okay
not questioning the shaykh i'm not
questioning what they put out we're
beneath them before we know exactly so i
i asked him clearly i was like
what you are doing coming to the masjid
standing outside of the masjid while all
the other brothers are inside the masjid
together praying in congregation and you
choose to pray solo is this
uniting you bringing you together with
the other brothers or is this
literally what the government
regulations are trying to do
are you feeding into that exact dividing
and conquering
is it bringing you together with them or
is it dividing you is it making you feel
united or is it literally making you
feel disconnected bro and like he just
he didn't even care like he couldn't put
his ego aside he was just only 100 about
what the the scholars were saying i'm
like
and islam tells us verily do not be
extreme in matters of of faith do not be
going into one extreme or another
extreme islam is the middle path you
know so we're not going to be here
super you know
into one extreme saying oh forget these
government regulations we're not going
to abide by the law we're just going to
do
shoulder to shoulders
which is fine
by the way but you get what i mean and
forget this health inspector walks in
and shuts down the mosque
then what good have you done
but we're not going to the other extreme
either we're out here praying in the
grass outside bro because we don't want
to be in the magic because our prayer is
not invalid
this context bro and people are lacking
this context to find that middle path
and i'm not saying that the same ruling
can apply to multiple people but there's
context subhan allah
you know you might look at a brother and
wonder why is he praying standing up you
were telling us something about this
you know because he couldn't he couldn't
pray uh sitting down yeah yeah so um
a lot of people as far as i know they
justify praying with their hands instead
of right over the left on the chest or
stomach area they justify their hands
being down
because imam muhammad rahim allah did it
but what they don't know is that
was beaten so bad that he couldn't
really use his arms so he had to kind of
pray like that subhanallah as far as i
know so
um yeah context is everything uh that
but this is the thing you know imam
malik rehab allah he said that the um
the type of of
i wouldn't blame either parties i
wouldn't blame you i wouldn't blame him
the the brother that prayed alone
because at the end of the day especially
especially if you look kind of from i
mean i don't want to say anything that
sounds like shirk you know but from the
perspective of allah allah
basically
tells us in the quran if you don't know
go to those who know so if you get a
ruling
from a sheikh that's wrong
believing you're doing what is pleasing
allah you won't be sinful actually the
sheikh himself is not sinful as long as
he's doing his best because there's a
hadith that says the shaykh that does is
that tries to find a ruling according to
allah and the messenger saul i said
and he gets it right he gets two rewards
if he gets it wrong he gets one he's
still rewarded even just for trying if
even if he gets the wrong
um ruling in the end and like i
mentioned 95 percent of
of the rulings is different of opinion
to begin with
so you mentioned falling to extremes and
stuff
and uh
i think people kind of
fighting over even things like how to
pray and stuff that's an extreme in and
of itself i'm not talking about you
specifically because obviously you
weren't fighting right but even the
other brother you know
kind of you said he wouldn't let his ego
down right in that case if he had to
relate to you well i just relate to you
it probably wouldn't have been a big
deal
right but getting into the whole
discussion of no this is bidad this is
wrong this is
this is an opinion of some shaykh
but some people use your uncle bro yeah
yeah some people
they'll take the actual valid opinions
of the
and act as if they're not even muslim
literally there are some you know i'm
not going to name grace but there are
some groups that are so extreme if you
don't believe the same strain of the
meth hub that they follow then
this is haram
haram
at the end of the day why do we enter
jannah please tell me muslim yes
why do we enter jannah the mercy of
allah because of the mercy of allah not
because of our good deeds not because we
were always like okay we have to find
the perfect life where we don't do any
sins and we can't show anyone we're
sinning and we always get the perfect
ruling on everything i'm not saying
that's not important but ultimately at
the end of the day nothing matters if
you don't have a sound heart and if you
don't have the mercy of allah you're not
entering jannah you're not going
anywhere near jannah
so at the end of the day do you want to
live a life where you're trying to help
your brothers and sisters and and get
the mercy of allah insha'allah
or you're just out here caught up
thinking you know it's all in your
control and you're going to get jannah
no matter what because even that is a
big sin in and of itself thinking that
you're going to go to jannah being so
arrogant knowing i'm going to go to
jannah of course why wouldn't i
i could do everything in my power you
know
stuck for allah
guys if you made it this far smash that
like button comment down below hashtag
don't judge
and
insha allah let us know how you like
this episode this is episode two
inshallah stay tuned for episode three
lots of podcasts coming your way
inshallah same time every single friday
and with that being said anh would like
to do a closing dua bismillah
don't work on bro you're making nervous
just look the other way
i i have it in my head but i don't want
to like butcher it give it your all bro
bismillah just try
nah
i forgot
fair bro
rami do you want to do the honors
with that being
foreign